charred remnants from people's lives
peaked through a blanket of snow
a winter storm hit colorado's boulder
county days after fire had engulfed
entire neighborhoods
the fires began in northern denver and
within hours they destroyed a thousand
homes after sweeping through superior
town and the city of louisville
you know these are quiet little blocks
where kids play
he did
this local resident and his dog were
lucky not to lose their home
walking through
that devastation yesterday was
on one hand heartbreaking because you
know that people lost uh their their all
their their belongings um their memories
that were in those homes families that
were raised there
u.s president joe biden has offered
funds to help with the recovery
and the county sheriff says a search is
continuing for victims the scenes are
still hot they're still you know
deep in debris hot debris covered with
snow so it's a very difficult task
scientists say unusual weather had a
domino effect
early torrential rain led to prairie
grasses growing high a dry winter turned
the ground to kindling and powerful
winds downed power lines igniting the
grass
they blame climate change
this kind of event that happens in
december with a lot of rain to increase
fuels early in the year and then no rain
later in the year that dries them out is
very much associated with climate change
some lives have been lost and thousands
more upended
if climate change is to blame
many will question how can they prevent
this destruction from reoccurring in the
future
laura about manly al jazeera